i'm joined today by gretchen baki who is
author of the grid the fraying wires
between Americans and our energy future
Gretchen it's so great to talk to you
know we talk so much about the move
towards alternative and renewable
sources of energy we talk about the
political implications and and the sort
of economic implications but one thing
that's often missing from that
conversation is sort of the reality of
the electrical grid that were working
with and some of the limitations that
exist and we'll sort of have to be dealt
with if we really want to move away from
fossil fuels which I believe that we
should be trying to do let's start as
broadly as you want to I mean what are
some of the limitations that need to be
considered I think the main thing that
people don't quite grasp when there's
when when when thinking about the energy
transition is that electricity can't
really be stored right now and what that
means is that as it's made its used it's
this very instantaneous product so as
it's made its used and that means that
if we make it with something like coal
it's a very steady production and if we
make it with something like wind it's a
very unsteady production because the
amount of electricity changes as the as
the rate of the wind blowing changes and
so that's called variable generation and
it's the more of it that we put into our
grid we tend to think of it as
renewables but not all renewables are
variable and the more we put of it we
put into the grid the the harder it is
to manage this sort of perfect balancing
of how much electricity we use in any
instant and how much electricity we
produce in that same instant because
electricity is essentially instantaneous
so I'm almost never more than a minute
between when it's made and when it's
used and this is particularly relevant
for people who already have or are
thinking of moving to solar power in
their home unless you actually have a
means of storing electricity right
unless you have an actual battery set up
any excess electricity that is harvested
by your home solar system is not stored
for your future use but rather goes back
into the grid and as you
is almost instant state instantaneously
used by someone else I mean is that
generally the way that it works yeah and
I think that's one of the things that I
was really confused about for a long
time was why people could have diesel
generators and seemed to be like when
there was a blackout they would be able
to power things in their house but if
you have solar panels you can't and like
many people I thought that was something
that the utilities work on somehow
scheming to make it that you so you
couldn't go off the grid completely but
actually diesel generators have all
these very heavy pieces inside of them
and so when you turn on a light switch
there's a kind of inertial force inside
the generator that allows it to balance
your house so the the power you have on
or turning on or turning off in any
moment it has to be balanced by the
amount of electricity that generator is
producing so again the fossil fuel and
then this heavy piece of equipment
enable you to run your house even
without storage where solar panels
obviously you're not going to have any
any power at night but even so you turn
on your light there's no way for our
source for a solar panel to adjust to
that without some kind of storage so you
turn on a light you're asking for more
electricity from that system but that
system is just producing electricity
based on how much Sun is hitting it at
that moment and you know we don't use we
don't even think in terms of like okay
it's midday and it's really sunny so I'm
going to run everything right now right
our fridge turns on or freezer turns on
it goes off we turn on the lights we
turn them off and all of that has to be
balanced in some way by something and
right now that something is the grid and
people like the grid it's not there's
not a there's not really a strong
movement I think against the grid but
there is this sense of like why can't I
be energy independent and the reason for
that is when you turn on a light and you
have solar panels that extra electricity
needs to come from somewhere so it comes
through the grid and if the grid is down
then it doesn't it doesn't come from
anywhere and as part of the path forward
on this I mean Elon Musk from Tesla has
talked about the home battery systems
that they're working on that within a
few years he says will be
affordable I mean is is that the type of
solution that you see is the most likely
to this problem I think it's very hard
to see the future because i think that
people really like the idea of being
part of a larger electricity system it's
it was very rare in my research that i
found people that wanted to wanted some
kind of energy wanted to be isolated all
the time they're happy to produce for
the grid solar panels in particular like
very happy to produce for the grid
during the day time to to draw from the
grid at night time so i think that that
there is a possibility certainly with
those home battery storage systems that
you could be energy independent all the
time so you wouldn't need the grid at
all but i think what's more likely is
that people will start to use those so
that they have power when the power is
out on the larger system in from and and
that was a lot of what was happening
when i was doing my research is that a
lot of the frustration i found with the
electricity system part of it was this
feeling of like we want more renewables
which is which is very hard to manage
and i think there's a lot of work going
in that direction by people who do
manage the grid right now but not fast
enough right there's there's a lot of
anger with utilities in particular for
not making that transition quickly
enough but the other big frustration was
my powers out all the time i have solar
panels why can't I just have my power
beyond like why do I have to also have a
diesel backup generator so this movement
from producing power independently but
also trying to be green at home and
wanting the larger electricity system to
be green as well so if we step aside a
little bit from the storage aspect of it
I'd love to talk a little bit about some
of the other ways in which the grid is
relatively susceptible to outside forces
Abby we we have mostly in this country
elevated power lines where anything from
whether to a squirrel can cause pretty
significant interruptions is that one of
the biggest sort of liabilities in the
American electrical grid right now and
you mean the the power lines being above
ground yeah it's certainly certainly
it's a it
in part because the greatest threat to
the grid right now is growing trees okay
if they were underground that would be
less of a problem it's really hard to
cut back all of the foliage that is just
up and coming over this huge nation
right it's always just going up and up
and up and sort of grabbing at power
lines and so yes it's not always the
answer to bury though if you have some
place like Florida with a high sort of a
high title um I don't know I think the
word is scaled but the water comes a
very high title ii or when when it's
very wet you don't want to bury you
don't want to bury lines and you don't
even want critical infrastructure at
ground level you want to start putting
stuff up you want to put your
substations on hills so for some places
it's quite it's quite a good idea to
bury lines in other places it's a less
good idea the grid is weirdly local so
we have three of them in the US and
they're each gigantic through these huge
machines are sort of one for the west
one for the east and one for Texas but
nevertheless it's also extremely local
in how it's designed how different
states have been keeping it up the kinds
of laws there are laws that are federal
but there are many laws that are very
particular to states or even two
counties or two municipalities and so
taking into account the weather in
particular places matters for answering
that question and but it's also
extremely expensive to bury lines yeah
and that also gets towards what sort of
underlying this which is a I don't know
if I would call it a jurisdictional
issue but certainly one of ownership
which is that there's not like a single
entity that owns or controls or
maintains the grid right i mean as your
sort of talking about you're talking
about municipalities and a lot of
smaller entities that are part of this
grid mm-hmm and even manage their own
grid and there are many municipal like
Los Angeles for example has it manages
its own grid even though that grid is
connected into the entire gigantic grid
which covers the whole of the West it's
still that particular piece of it like
where they're buying electricity from
how much they're paying for it who's
maintaining the lines all of that is is
managed by the municipality and some
municipal grids are very very small I I
talk about in the book Rancho Cucamonga
which has one street light but they have
a municipal power windows municipal
our governance and people again are sort
of organizing suburbs etc as they get
frustrated with the the rate of change
to a more renewable renewably powered
system they are they'll just get towns
or suburbs together and they'll
disaggregate it's called from the big
grid and take over their own little
piece of it to manage it for themselves
and so that's sort of that so that
happens legally in the state so it's
both big and you know very very small
very very local and absolutely you know
nationally gigantic and I think that's
where you see a lot of the excitement
about what's happening right now I know
most people don't really see the grid or
think about the grid but it's it's
changing radically at this exact moment
in time uh and lots of people are
causing that change to happen in
different ways well it is a hugely
important issue particularly when we
have the conversation about when and how
will we get off of fossil fuels it's
something that that could not be more
important again we've been talking about
the book the grid the fraying wires
between Americans and our energy future
and we've been speaking with the book's
author Gretchen baki thanks so much for
talking to us about this yeah my
pleasure thank you